nous ne pouvons pas penser le monde de
demain sans penser la question de la
préservation de notre environnement et
la question de l'écologie et ce sujet
nous ne pouvons pas le laisser
l'abandonner aux plus extrémistes du
paysage politique que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui
il faut donc la droite républicaine
d'abord parce que c'est son histoire
renoue avec ses grands enjeux que sont
ceux la préservation de l'environnement
le premier président de la république a
créé un ministère de l'environnement
c'est georges pompidou les grandes
déclarations de jacques chirac à
johannesbourg sur la maison commune qui
brûle c'est notre famille politique
le grenelle de l'environnement nicolas
sarkozy jean-louis borloo c'est notre
famille politique
bref la droite républicaine a quelque
chose à dire sur ces questions comment
concilier notre agriculture
le développement de notre économie avec
l'enjeu environnemental comment faire en
sorte que nous nous sacrifions pas ce
que nous avons de plus précieux notre
bien environnementale comment faire en
sorte que l'on ne dresse pas les uns
contre les autres ce sujet là nous
allons le traité voilà pourquoi je vais
débuter avec plusieurs de mes collègues
députés sénateurs et élus locaux pendant
plus d'une année un tour de france de
l'environnement j'irai chaque mois dans
un département rencontrer les acteurs
agricoles des acteurs associatifs des
femmes et des hommes qui au quotidien
sont engagés sur la question
environnementale et au terme de ces
plusieurs longs mois de travail
nous formerons des propositions qui
seront capables de porter un projet
d'avenir oui la droite républicaine est
de retour sur les questions de
l'environnement
et c'est par le terrain que nous
recommençons
[Musique]